I know he doesn't believe in government  I know it doesn't know that much about  what is it risk to shut it down but I  think that it would be let's not talk  about what might happen let's talk about  what we can do right now to keep  government open there is strong  bipartisan support to do that the only  obstacle is the President of the United  States and by the way the president said  in Mexico is going to pay for this and  what he said well have it in our paper  well they're gonna pay for it when we  have a new free trade agreement and that  money  what money what money what money that  money will be used to pay for the wall  the money that businesses make what  money is he talking about that's going  to go pay for the wall it just isn't it  just doesn't measure up any other  questions